hey youtubers is charlie so we just got
the first big trailer for Doctor Who
series 8 its way longer than all the
previous teasers they posted so this is
gonna be a full breakdown into darkness
the funny thing is is I was actually
working on a special Dalek series 8
video whenever this was happening so I'm
gonna post that video later so they'll
be like double Doctor Who today hello
any new people if you're just finding me
for the first time I do weekly Doctor
Who videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything I've got a lot of special
stuff planned for when episodes actually
start and that's gonna be on august
twenty-third so trailer time I know
there's been a lot of leaks lately too
if you're one of the people who has read
the scripts or seen that black and white
episode please use spoiler tags if
you're gonna comment on them I haven't
seen the leaks and I haven't read those
scripts so all the rumors that I'm going
to be talking about during this trailer
are just rumors I don't consider them
spoilery so this is just going to be a
shot-for-shot breakdown of the stuff we
see in the trailer as well as the
voice-over so we start off with a shot
of the TARDIS controls in that explosion
that we see in all the previous trailers
moving through a montage of a new shot
of a quarter that we've never seen
before it could be the inside of the
TARDIS but I've never seen any
passageways in the TARDIS that look like
this there are rumors that Clara and the
doctor will be traveling inside a Dalek
in series 8 so this could be from inside
a Dalek that theory is kind of supported
by the appearance of Clara looking like
she's in a waking dream that moves
through a close-up of a Dalek istock it
also kind of reminds me of Dalek Oswin
from the series 7 opener I just love the
sound effects in the way the images
pulse to especially the Dalek it just
makes it sound like a heartbeat this
Clara is the Clara from the Christmas
special though she's got a new haircut
in the series 8 promo pics so we're not
looking at a different version of her
it's the same Clara the voice-over life
returns is both a play on Dalek life and
the doctor's new life Allah Capaldi so
next we actually get a really good shot
of the TARDIS when it's not exploding it
looks exactly like Matt Smith's new
TARDIS from the 2012 christmas special
the snowmen so this kind of confirms
that Peter Capaldi will for all intents
and purposes have the same TARDIS I know
everyone's been asking about his sonic 2
but here we can see him holding Smith
sonic so it seems like he won't be
getting a new one anytime soon maybe in
series 9 one of my favorite parts in
this trailer is that voice over the
Dalek was over of life prevailing like
we're all buzzing because of the doctors
triumph in the Christmas
and his new set of fancy regenerations
but underneath it the Dalek is also
talking about Dalek life prevailing the
Time Lords and the Daleks are the two
most enduring racism it only makes sense
that for every victory of the doctors
the Daleks also achieved some sort of
victory so here's the first full
beautiful shot of Capaldi from actual
footage and he's wearing a tie which is
a nice callback to tenant this seems
like a temporary costume since he's been
revealed to not have any neck wear with
his official main series 8 costume there
have been a lot of behind-the-scenes
pictures from them filming a Victorian
London episode so this might be from
that episode I just love the way he
looks and that hard stare it seems like
everyone is thinking of Capaldi's
defining trait as the doctor so far is
his eyes and right now I agree just
based on these images it's also the
first time we've heard Capaldi
acknowledging himself as the doctor to
someone else this mechanical man seems
like he's also from that Victorian
episode there were a lot of rumors that
they would be bringing back the
clockwork robots from the girl in the
fireplace and I think that this answers
that no this is not clockwork robots but
it is a robot the funny thing though is
that this bird looking robot reminds me
a lot of the clockwork owl from Clash of
the Titans Bubo like a terminator
version of boob oh that can't be good so
yes clockwork but it seems like not the
clockwork robots that were used to
seeing Capaldi states that he's over
2000 years old which is interesting
because it was kind of hard to pinpoint
his age after he spent so long on
trenzalore on the Christmas special the
best estimate right now is that he's 21
hundred years old here's one of the new
aliens and it looks like he's wearing
one of the doctors spacesuits so it's
possible that he could be friendly I
can't imagine the doctor just handing
out space suits to anybody that comes
along no idea which episode this appears
in but it looks like they're in a bank
vault and that new missus delphox
villain character works at a bank in the
future so they might be appearing in the
same episode the different images in
this montage of explosions don't
necessarily have to be from the same
episode but it's possible that they're
all from that future delphox episode to
the bank story is rumored to be heist
that takes place in the far future in
those containers look fairly futuristic
so this could all be from that episode
here's a nighttime shot of Victorian
London that rumored first episode then
the doctor is talking to Clara about
fixing his mistakes he looks like he's
wearing his new
you costume even though you can't see
the red lining which is very reminiscent
of the Third Doctor's cape for any
classic who fans Clara is also wearing a
new leather jacket so presumably this
scene is after things have kind of
calmed down like after the TARDIS
stopped crashing at the end of the
Christmas special he says they're going
into darkness and that could mean a
couple of things it could literally mean
the void between universes or something
like the Medusa cascade something
outside of normal space the doctor has
claimed that everything that lived in
the void like the dogs and the Cybermen
are dead that was during doomsday but
during journeys and we learned that a
bunch of people were living in the
Medusa cascade so they could be playing
around with that it could also be from
that rumor Dalek story them going inside
the darkness of a Dalek like inside a
Dalek Magic School Bus from Hell style
then we see Madame vastra pretty much
confirming paternoster Victorian episode
Clara's falling down a shaft this could
be anywhere TARDIS Dalek or somewhere in
the future like some sort of building
here's my favorite trailer shot t-rex in
London fairly self-explanatory if you
look at the background smokestack and
some of these hats it suggests that this
is also from that Victorian London
episode cannot wait for an explanation
of why there is a t-rex in London I know
a lot of people weren't big fans of
dinosaurs on a spaceship but I totally
love that story this shot of the robot
is from mark davis's episode robots of
Sherwood Tom Riley plays raman hood I
can't wait to see it it's like a full-on
Ren Faire episode of Doctor Who so if
you're a ren faire fan you're gonna love
this episode here's Capaldi on horseback
also in Victorian London no idea why
he's wearing a nightgown this shot of
the atmosphere venting out of the room
looks like it's from inside the TARDIS
it could be of another room in the far
future though then we see full-on Daleks
cut with a montage that looks like the
TARDIS traveling inside the Medusa
cascade you know or the void between
universes right now I'm thinking Medusa
cascade is more likely due to the Davros
speech from the last trailer plus
there's the green highlights then we
actually see the scene of the doctor
asking Clara fees a good man they use
the voiceover of this in the last
trailer but it seems way less sinister
the way they use it in this scene so
he's probably just asking her genuinely
because he's still trying to make sense
of his mind after the regeneration when
she says she doesn't know I'm wondering
if that's because of the new personality
and she knows the doctor has changed in
isn't quite sure who he is or if she's
realizing that she never really knew the
doctor at least as well she thought she
did and that's pretty much it I'm
thinking based on the footage they used
all these trailer scenes are from the
first couple of episodes again if you've
read those leaked scripts please use
spoiler tags if you're going to comment
but because the doctor talked about
correcting a lot of his mistakes I'm
really wondering if series 8 is going to
deal with a lot of familiar places you
know even if a lot of the characters
change so in related news i had that
Dalek video that I was finishing is this
trailer came so I'm just gonna finish
that up and post it in a couple hours be
sure to subscribe to get that we're
really almost a couple weeks away from
the premiere so if you bought a ticket
to the Doctor Who world tour please post
pictures because it is going to be
awesome feel free to post them on my
Facebook page there's a link to that in
the description for anyone that does not
have a ticket don't worry I am expecting
another trailer before the premiere so
we will get some new footage right now
click here to get that Dalek video I'll
add the annotation as soon as I post it
a little bit and click here to learn all
about Sherlock series for they just
dumped a whole bunch of information so
it's really exciting thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys in a
little bit high fives
you